first get you ingredients to hand eggs  should be out of the fridge and at room  temperature soaked saffron in warm water  saffron is the most expensive spice in  the world made from the dried stigma of  crocus flowers but even a pinch gives a  fantastic taste and a wonderful color  next separate three eggs put the yolks  into a mixing bowl add Dijon mustard  finely chopped garlic the drained  saffron and a squeeze of lemon  then mix whisking constantly and oil  slowly it won't take forever for perfect  flavor use half olive oil and half  vegetable oil  where the mayonnaise comes together  season a smooth thick consistency means  it's done  top with saffron  rich delicious and perfect with  everything from seafood to sandwiches  and chips  my sister cools down even more and then  combined start mixing that in it's  reading three fingers one in front two  behind and this part of the knuckle